project natal is essentially xbox 360's
controller pre-gaming where essentially
all you need is life experience I just
jumped in have fun no controller is
necessary we essentially are able to
look at the scene and fundamentally
understand what is going on and
fundamentally hear what's going on and
based on those two inputs we are able to
come up with a whole new set of
experiences and a whole new way of
telling stories that has never been done
before what excites me most about my job
what doesn't excite me to death I mean
this is literally every child's dream to
be able to come into work every day and
fundamentally change an industry we are
right now going through one of those
fast and furious transition periods if
you are lucky enough to get to work in
that transition period and healthy and
she moved from a world that was the
world that will be it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
the world that was is this world where
where humans have to understand the
languages of machines the the world that
we are we are beginning to paint as a
world where by essentially machines
understand the languages of humans
we cannot sit and program a reaction to
reaction we have to rethink the paradigm
and essentially teach the computer to
perceive the world and that really
translates into really teaching the
sensor to classify the world much like
you did the first one is just going to
people's living rooms for the dorm rooms
anywhere where people are likely to have
the devices we go in and essentially
film terabytes and terabytes most users
in their natural habitats right into the
next two environments there's also two
other ways of gathering day that one is
the mocap one where we actually just go
down to Hollywoodland and we sit in
mocap studios and we essentially film
people much in the same way that you
would Gollum in the Lord of the Rings
kind of thing now if you think about
living room as being the natural
environment this is a synthetic
environment right where I essentially
have actors sitting here I have a
director and much like a movie we have a
set of shots they need to go through
I'll show you one in the dark so that
you can actually see the joints placed
on them and this is the benefit mocap at
the end of the day what you care about
in the human is not the body parts is
the absolute eyes I'm doing a racing
game I'm tracking a wrists or your
elbows or your shoulders or all of the
above
what if I'm a woman and I'm wearing a
skirt and I'm gonna play soccer or do
you to play soccer you're gonna have to
be able to see your kneecaps in your
feet
now if you're any skirt how do you do
that does that look like from the
perspective of the brain similar in
pants note at that point are going to
have a lot of cloth over it
and your knees are going to be
essentially what you see through the
cloth deprivation right I put my knee
forward I'm deforming a piece of cloth
and now the signal here is essentially a
very different than a guy wearing
hampson doing this so so in terms of
training not only to be trained across
body types we also train the girl across
different attire we also train across
different you know hair characteristics
hats not ass beard enough
the bulk of the time we spend is
creating a platform that creates a brain
that can classify and understand of your
world if we can create a brain that can
understand of your world you can create
anything you want right because your
guarantee that anything you can come up
with you can actually do which then goes
down to hey all you need is life
experience as long as you know how to do
something in the real world that will
replicate one to one to what you want to
do anymore
in the digital world
we understand the historic moment in
time we get it we're super excited about
it the world of TV years from now will
be dramatically different Telus journey
it's going to take us a long time to
complete chain an entire computer
industry
it starts in interactive entertainment
it starts next box and that's our focus
right now but we do see incredible
applications from a Productivity
perspective from a healthcare
perspective from a from a enterprise
perspective you name it it's hard as
soon as you change the paradigm right
can you say I can fundamentally
understand humans that's widely
applicable anywhere anywhere
you